Here's a different hem treatment.
That's great
when knitting highly textured stitch
patterns like G carriage
or tuck stitch patterns.
We'll be reversing the standard hung hem.
So put on your thinking
cap and let's get started.
One thing to consider is the fact
that most G carriage and tuck stitch
patterns work up wider
than stockinette stitch.
If you like your hems to pull
in a bit like ribbing, great.
If not, you may need to add a few stitches
to your Caston to make the hem wider.
Then decrease evenly before
starting your stitch pattern.
First, establish the public
and the private side of your knitting.
In other words, which side of the garment
is going to be facing you
when you're knitting?
For this sample, I've set up my G carriage
pattern so that the wrong or the private
side of the garment is facing me,
just like I normally do if I
was knitting stockinette.
But I do need to keep this in mind when
hanging the reverse Stockinette
or the mock-garter hem.
I'm going to e-wrap Caston.
If you prefer Cast on with waste yarn and
Ravel cord, but I find e-Wrap to be faster.
Even though this is going
to be a G-carriage sweater.
I'm using my main carriage for the hem.
If you're familiar with knitting regular
stockinette stitch hung hems,
this part is going to be the same.
We will knit half of the hem at a
slightly tighter than garment tension.
We're going to call the private side
the facing. So this will be
the facing, that first half.
In this case, I knit twelve rows.
Now knit a turning row at a larger
tension, a looser tension.
Next, knit the other half of the hem,
which will be the public side of the hem.
At garment tension.
Scrap your work off or take
it off on a Garter bar.
Because I've established that the public
side of my garment
is going to be away from me.
As I'm knitting, I'll turn and rehang
the stitches from the Garter bar.
Now the knit side of the hem
will be facing me.
Think of it this way.
I want to encase the stockinette side of this piece
and let the Purl side show.
Once the hem is back on the machine,
pick up the eWrap Caston
stitches back on those needles.
This time the purl side
of the facing is towards you.
Knit one row at a loose tension
across all the stitches.
Reset your carriage to garment tension,
or start up your Garter carriage
and knit your garment piece.
This tuck stitch stitch pattern
will be knit with the Purl side-
the public side will be facing
me as I knit the garment.
In this case,
we'll do one thing a little bit
differently to knit a faux Garter hem
for a right side facing
textured stitch pattern.
Knit the hem the same way.
E-wrap cast on. Knit the facing of your
band at a slightly tighter than garment
tension. Knit a loose turning row.
Knit the public side of the hem
and remove on waist yarn.
This time a Garter bar is
not going to help you.
You're going to hang the e-Wrap Caston
with the knit side facing you or
the stockinette side facing you.
Then rehang the hem stitches
from the waste yarn to form the hem.
So it's this section you'll be doing
backwards from the first method.
Knit one row plain and begin
knitting your garment.
I hope you'll think about mixing things up
when you knit your next garment with hems.
Thank you for watching the Knit.
It Now Learning Library has hundreds
of techniques on a variety
of subjects at all skill levels.
Please consider a subscription
and let us help you be a better machine
knitter.